you know it's funny usually in a
domestic defamation dispute like this
the internet has all kinds of opinions
but they've been completely silent about
johnny depp and amber hurd
it's weird
[Music]
oh okay
yeah so johnny depp is suing amber hurt
she is suing him at exactly the same
time this is all incredibly crazy and
this latest suit and countersuit is
already turning into a circus of course
for hollywood celebrities leading public
lives it seems like there's no such
thing as a truly private matter and this
has certainly been the case for amber
hurd who has publicly accused her
ex-husband johnny depp of subjecting her
to years of physical and emotional abuse
during their marriage and depp for his
part
has vehemently denied the allegations
accusing herd of defaming him with
fabricated claims while portraying herd
as the real abuser and while heard has
primarily aired her grievances to the
media depp has opted to take his fight
to the courtroom in both the uk and the
state of virginia now determining the
truth of domestic violence allegations
is invariably a challenging prospect as
a result the public's response to these
allegations has been incredibly
polarizing with herd and depth having
their own supporters and detractors
alike so legal eagles let's talk about
the johnny depp amber heard saga we'll
cover the facts leading up to the
decades-long dispute between the former
celebrity couple review the
multi-million dollar defamation lawsuits
in the uk in the u.s that have been
brought as a result and talk about how
johnny depp can sue twice for basically
the same thing
[Music]
now the former hollywood couple's
virginia courtroom confrontation is the
culmination of 10 years of love
heartbreak and abuse allegations between
the pirates of the caribbean actor and
the justice league actress here is the
timeline of how this feud leapt from the
tabloids to the courtroom
in 2012 johnny depp and amber heard
began dating following depp's split from
his longtime partner french model
actress singer vanessa pereidi depp in
parody dated for 14 years and they
shared two children together in february
of 2015 depp and heard officially tied
the knot but as quickly as the pair fell
in love things fell apart just as
swiftly on may 21 2016 the lapd
responded to a saturday night call in
which heard alleged domestic abuse law
enforcement officials at the time stated
they found quote no evidence of any
crime and her did not file any charges
on may 23 2016 heard officially filed
for divorce from depp citing
irreconcilable differences four days
later hurt appeared in a los angeles
court with a bruised cheek to request a
temporary restraining order against depp
in a sworn declaration heard alleged
that her then-husband 23 years her
senior had quote violently attacked her
and thrown a cell phone at her face with
extreme force photographs submitted to
the court show heard with a large bruise
on her face along with broken bottles
picture frames and shattered glass on
the floor heard alleges that quote
during the entirety of our relationship
johnny has been verbally and physically
abusive end quote heard further claimed
that she quote endured excessive
emotional verbal and physical abuse
which has included angry hostile
humiliating and threatening assaults to
me whenever i question his authority or
disagreed with him now in her filings
heard recounted an alleged april 21st
assault wherein depp allegedly came home
drunk as herd's birthday party was
ending threw a champagne bottle at a
wall grabbed her hair violently shoved
her to the floor and heard also alluded
to one severe incident in december 2015
when i truly feared for my life
people magazine would later publish a
photo purportedly from this incident
in opposition to these motions depp's
lawyers claimed the allegations were
false and accused her to quote
attempting to secure a premature
financial resolution by alleging abuse
on may 27th of that year the judge
granted herd's temporary restraining
order ordering depth to stay at least
100 yards away and avoid all contact
until a june 17th follow-up hearing that
would decide whether the order should be
made permanent but hours before the
scheduled hearing heard and depp
released a joint statement announcing
that they had resolved their dispute
quote our relationship was intensely
passionate and at times volatile but
always bound by love neither party has
made false accusations for financial
gain there was never any intent of
physical or emotional harm now in august
of 2016 depp and heard reached a divorce
settlement with heard allegedly pledging
to donate seven million dollars to the
american civil liberties union and the
children's hospital of los angeles in
august of 2021 a new york judge
partially granted depp's motion to force
the aclu to produce documents to show if
she did in fact donate the seven million
dollars a fact that remains contested by
depp and after the divorce was finalized
in january of 2017
depp's attorney laura wasser released
the following statement quote we're
pleased to put this unpleasant chapter
in mr depp and his family's lives behind
them having his request for entry of the
dissolution of judgment granted today
made it a particularly lucky friday the
13th now while depp's attorneys declared
their client's intention to put this
chapter behind him the british tabloids
would not extend mr depp's such a
courtesy
which takes us to how the uk lawsuit got
filed now following the divorce both
heard and depp continued to pursue their
respective acting careers heard reprised
her role as uh mera from aquaman for
joss whedon's justice league in 2017
while depp returned his captain jack
sparrow for the fifth pirates of the
caribbean installment but as depp was
preparing to reprise his role as the
eponymous villain in jk rowling's
fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald the sun a british tabloid
fired a shot across the pond by
rehashing herds abuse allegations on
april 27 2018 the sun executive editor
dan wooten published an article entitled
gone potty how can jk rowling be
genuinely happy casting wife beater
johnny depp in the new fantastic beast
film
writing that quote overwhelming evidence
was filed to show johnny depp engaged in
domestic violence against his wife amber
heard wooten accused the harry potter
author of quote providing depp total
rehabilitation in the eyes of the movie
industry by allowing depth to star in
the fantastic beasts sequel now depp's
response to the article was swift on
june 1st 2018 depp sued the parent
company that publishes the sun in
england for libel demanding a minimum
200 000 plus legal fees depp's attorneys
argued the article defamed him by
presuming the actor was guilty of
domestic violence against his former
wife highlighting the use of the term
wifebeater now depp's counsel maintained
that these quote reputation destroying
and career-ending allegations were
untrue and cause the actor quote serious
harm the threshold standard for
defamation in england
in its defense the sun's parent company
argued that there was sufficient
evidence to show that depp was quote
violent towards misheard on multiple
occasions
during their relationship making the
term wife beater an accurate statement
and in support of its claims the company
relied on 14 alleged incidents of
physical abuse against her that
purportedly occurred between 2013 and
2016. though neither dept nor heard were
on trial the case was essentially a
dress rehearsal for the pair's virginia
defamation trial with both depp and
heard giving live testimony detailing an
array of graphic allegations when depp
took the stand he acknowledged
wide-ranging drug problems which he
referred to as quote the monster but
accused herd of making up allegations
and insisting that he was quote not a
violent person especially with a woman a
characterization that was backed up in
sworn statements from former partners
winona writer and vanessa parody depp
portrayed her as the aggressor in the
relationship accusing her of repeatedly
belittling him and frequently turning
physically violent during their
tumultuous marriage saying quote it was
sort of a rapid fire sort of endless
parade of insults quote you know looking
at me like i was a fool and i was having
difficulty in my mind of course and in
my heart dealing with that sort of
barrage
depp further alleged that herd would
sometimes strike out in anger or
frustration and regarding an alleged
head-butting incident in december of
2015 at his la penthouse depp testified
he was trying to hold her back
from hitting him and their foreheads
collided by accident depp also detailed
a purported march 2015 argument in
australia that led to part of his finger
being sliced off due to a thrown vodka
bottle depp contended that heard saw him
drinking for the first time in a while
and she threw a bottle of vodka that
narrowly missed his head before throwing
a larger bottle that did strike his head
photos provided by depp's council
purported to show depth with a bloody
finger and a cigarette burn on his face
for her part her denied injuring depth
contending that her ex severed his own
finger during a drug and alcohol binge
after repeatedly smashing a wall-mounted
phone against the wall heard testified
the depth fueled by drugs and alcohol
hit slapped and shoved her pulling her
hair and threw bottles quote like
grenades at heard at various incidents
between 2013 and 2016. on
cross-examination her denied the
characterization of depp's lawyers that
she was the one who struggled with drugs
and alcohol
that she was the one who abused him and
that she was the one who
was controllingly manipulative
not deaf now under cross examination
depp admitted it was possible that he
destroyed the phone stating quote i
remember ripping the phone off the wall
depp also admitted that he had
previously taken responsibility for
severing his finger though depp claimed
that he was only trying to protect herd
when he had to tell the production
company the injury prevented him from
working on set and depp also confirmed
that he wrote messages
for heard in blood paint and lipstick
including quote i love you and good luck
which he did to indicate he felt the
relationship was over
and in a trial that had the couple
airing out their dirty laundry depp also
detailed an alleged incident involving
literal dirty laundry supposedly on the
night of herd's birthday party in april
2016 depp says he arrived late due to a
meeting he was attending that testified
that heard was furious with him hitting
him multiple times after the party ended
before he left and spent the night at
another home depp said that he planned
to retrieve items the next morning after
heard left for coachella but was told by
someone at the home who texted him a
photo not to return because
there was poop in the bed quote it was a
photograph of the bed our bed and on my
side of the bed was human fecal matter
so i understood why it wasn't a good
time to go down there
he continued my initial response to that
was i mean i laughed it was so outside
it was so bizarre and so grotesque that
i could only laugh depp had previously
claimed in a written statement that
heard or one of her friends were the
culprit and allege that heard had called
this quote just a harmless prank but
depp said that incident was when he knew
their marriage was over and a month
later heard filed for divorce
hurd has denied any role in this poo
donet suggesting the story is fabricated
simply to
humiliate her so yeah the british trial
was incredibly colorful
and after hearing all the evidence the
uk court sided with the sun and rejected
depp's libel claims in his november 2020
opinion justice andrew nichol concluded
that the sun had met its burden of proof
and that the sun's allegations that depp
engaged in unprovoked attacks and
violent conduct against his then wife
that caused her to be in fear for her
life were true quote on the balance of
the probabilities meaning the abuse
allegations were more likely than not to
be true the justice did not accept
depp's characterization of heard as a
gold digger who had quote constructed a
hoax and as an insurance policy in the
event the marriage fell apart among the
incidents the judge found to be
substantially true were the two events
alluded to in herd's 2016 application
for domestic violence restraining order
the may 2016 assault with depp's phone
and the severe december 2015 incident
where depp allegedly threw a decanter at
heard in the penthouse head-butted her
and pulled large chunks of hair from her
scalp before an appearance on james
corden's late late show and the justice
did not find depp's claim that hurd was
responsible for severing his fingertip
to be credible and as for the poop in
the bed incident while the judge blamed
the dog
for what it's worth i consider it
unlikely that miss heard or one of her
friends was responsible reasoning in
part that depp was out of the house at
the time of the incident and heard was
the one likely to suffer from
the effects the judge concluded quote it
was therefore a singularly ineffective
means for miss heard or one of her
friends to get back at mr depp your
mileage may vary on that reasoning in
response to the ruling depths
representative stated they found the
decision quote as perverse as it is
bewildering and immediately announced
their intention to appeal but in march
of 2021 depp's appeal was rejected and
the court of appeals ruled that the
lower court case was quote full and fair
and the trial judge conclusions quote
have not been shown to even arguably be
vitiated by any error or approach of
mistake of law and concluded the appeal
has no real prospect of success and that
there is no other compelling reason for
it to be heard on appeal depp's council
had argued they did not get a fair
hearing and that hurt was an unreliable
witness and as evidence of her
unreliability depp's counsel asserted
that herd has not kept her promise to
donate her 7 million divorce settlement
to charity and the fallout from depp's
spectacular defeat was immediate
following the november ruling depp
announced he was leaving the fantastic
beasts franchise after warner brother
requested his resignation and that takes
us to the good old us of a because what
makes depp's defeat so notable is that
the odds of prevailing on a libel claim
are much higher in england than in the
us in england the party accused of
defamation has the burden of proving
that their claim is quote substantially
true now that's the opposite in the u.s
where the defamed person has the burden
of proving that the libel of statements
are false
another reason us defamation cases are
hard to win is that public figures like
depp must prove the defamatory
statements were made with actual mouse
meaning that they were published with
knowledge of being false or reckless
disregard for their truth or falsity
again actual malice has nothing to do
with not liking a person it is an
evidentiary standard uh and it's not
particularly well named it's a legal
term of art and even with these built-in
advantages depp's still lost twice in
the uk
in the face of double defeat some have
characterized dep's legal strategy as a
complete flop and remember not only have
two british courts found herd's abuse
allegations to be substantially true but
depp's efforts have had the unintended
streizan effect of amplifying these
allegations after all if not for depp's
multiple lawsuits there would be no
reason for this channel to make a video
on this controversy to the millions of
legal eagles subscribers it's a case of
life imitating art i guess but depp's
defenders insist that the british trial
was not fairly decided that new evidence
has since come forward that paints a
different picture particularly with new
audio that purports to show her
admitting to abusing depp
so after all of this we find ourselves
back on american soil as depp attempts
another bite of the defamation apple
hoping this time he will be vindicated
and particularly an issue in the
american trial is an op-ed that amber
heard published on december 18 2018 six
months after depp filed the uk libel
action where she published in the
washington post
an article entitled i spoke up against
sexual violence and faced our culture's
wrath that has to change heard wrote
like many women i had been harassed and
sexually assaulted by the time i was of
college age but i kept quiet i did not
expect filing complaints to bring
justice and i didn't see myself as a
victim then two years ago i became a
public figure representing domestic
abuse and i felt the full force of our
culture's wrath for women who speak out
and in march 2019 depp responded to the
op-ed by filing a 50 million defamation
lawsuit against his ex-wife contending
heard's article contained quote
categorically and demonstrably false
claims of domestic abuse
the op-ed depended on the central
premise that ms heard was a domestic
abuse victim and that mr depp
perpetrated domestic violence against
her depp's lawyers also wrote in the
complaint quote her allegations are part
of an elaborate hoax to generate
positive publicity for miss heard and
advance her career the complaint which
again are just allegations from one side
charged that heard had incalculably
damaged the actor's reputation and
derailed his career highlighting that
disney fired debt from the pirates of
the caribbean franchise four days after
the publication of herd's article
and though the article does not mention
depth by name a party alleging
defamation need not be specifically
named so long as there are enough
identifying facts the person reading it
would reasonably understand that the
statements refer to the plaintiff and in
august of 2020 heard countersued for 100
million dollars arguing that depp's
denial of the abuse effectively accused
herd of committing perjury to obtain the
2016 domestic violence restraining order
which defamed her character heard also
accused depp of orchestrating an online
smear campaign against her in violation
of virginia's laws against online
harassment now some of you might be
wondering why this case is going to
trial at all given that it appears to
have already been litigated in another
forum in the uk and there is a principle
of law that prevents relitigation of the
same cause of action in a second lawsuit
between the same parties it's called
claim preclusion also referred to as
race judicana which is latin for a
matter decided basically it's like
double jeopardy but for civil suits and
there's also issue preclusion or
collateral estoppel preventing a party
from relitigating an issue once a court
has already ruled on it now herd's
lawyers tried to get the u.s lawsuit
thrown out because of some of the claims
that were already decided in the uk but
the judge denied the motion like most
things in law there were arguments on
both sides of these issues and in
particular amber heard was not a
defendant in the uk case she was only a
witness depp was a party though and he
appealed his case to the highest court
in the uk and lost but because heard
wasn't a party in the uk case remember
depp sued the son and the the sun's
parent company and a few other reasons
amber heard was not able to benefit from
claim preclusion and race judicata to
prevent debt from being able to sue in
virginia and then also american courts
reject foreign judgments that don't live
up to american standards of free speech
and there's a law the securing the
protection of our enduring and
established constitutional heritage act
prevents u.s courts from enforcing
foreign defamation judgments that don't
comport with first amendment protections
so even if depp had won his case and
then asked american courts to recognize
the judgment the court probably would
have rejected his lawsuit of course now
depp has a second bite at the apple and
if he wins it would be really unusual
given his loss in a country with a lower
standard for proving defamation but
either way it's entirely possible that
johnny depp's career is over and the
jury is out whether that's amber heard's
fault or not but the point may not be
about winning a legal victory but about
winning a pr victory and rehabilitating
depp's image and it seems like he's made
some progress in that respect though the
virginia trial has already turned into a
complete circus i'll have to do another
video summarizing all the craziness that
has already occurred including heard's
lawyer objecting to himself and johnny
depp becoming an expert on hearsay but
if johnny depp wins either legally or in
the court of public opinion he should
celebrate by making himself a nice meal
which he can do with today's sponsor
hellofresh hellofresh is a great way to
eat delicious fresh food while still
being healthy in fact hello fresh has a
variety of calorie smart and carb smart
recipes as well as pescetarian and
veggie options as well as a new
mediterranean line you can customize it
how you'd like you can swap out proteins
or get premium top of the line versions
now i'm a do-it-yourself person and i
have to say i was initially pretty
skeptical about hellofresh i'm a pretty
good cook so i didn't really think i
needed the help but i actually love it
and even for an experience cook
hellofresh delivers new ingredients and
recipes that i'd never try on my own
hellofresh generally keeps everyone's
favorite meals and then rotates new ones
in all the time most recently i've
enjoyed seasonal spring recipes like
sweet heat shrimp tempura bowls try
saying that one three times fast garden
spinach ricotta ravioli also a tongue
twister and one pod creamy lemon dill
chicken soup now i don't know about you
but i would never have attempted those
on my own especially just because it's
hard to say but honestly they are really
delicious no matter how hard it is to
actually say the titles and in fact i
usually increase the size of my
hellofresh servings so that i can enjoy
the leftovers for lunches and snacks
later on and it's not just meals
hellofresh's marketplace features
variety of add-ons for breakfast
desserts and seasonal snacks again huge
time savings as well and of course
everything was delivered straight to my
door so i didn't have to do any shopping
the produce actually gets to you faster
than a grocery store so it arrives in
peak freshness and flavor and all this
saves you time because hellofresh cuts
out meal planning and prep so the
recipes only take 20 to 30 minutes to
cook literally less time to cook than it
would normally take to do the shopping
for the meal and it's also really
sustainable since the ingredients are
pre-portioned there's less prep and less
food waste the packaging is almost
entirely made from recyclable or already
recycled content and hellofresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25 lower than that
of meals made from store-bought
groceries and it's 72 cheaper than
dining at a restaurant so if you'd like
to try hello fresh and you really should
you can go to hellofresh.com and use the
code legaleagle16 for up to 16 free
meals and three surprise gifts yes you
can actually get 16 free meals and that
includes free shipping all you have to
do is click on the link that's on screen
right now so again for up to 16 free
meals and three surprise gifts click on
the link that's on screen right now and
use the promo code legaleagle16 when you
check out plus clicking on the link
really helps out this channel and while
you're at it click on this playlist all
of my other videos so click on this link
or i'll see you in court